prime minister has never followed any
rules he does what he wants
and he gets away with it every time
the prime minister can't get away with
it again
will the prime minister
finally
do the decent thing and resign or will
his tory mps be forced to show him the
door being a politician is extremely
difficult regardless of how fair
transparent honest and well spoken you
are roughly half the population will
always despise you simply because both
of you have fundamentally different
beliefs considering this if you're a
politician you want to make sure that
you don't want to piss off the side that
supports you because then you're really
screwed as you can see from the clip
though that's exactly what uk's prime
minister boris johnson has done
over the past couple of months johnson
has been flamed by basically everyone in
parliament including most of the members
in his own party
in fact 27 out of the 31 scottish
conservative msps or basically
representatives have publicly voiced
their disapproval of johnson likewise
johnson's public approval rating has
never been more atrocious at the peak of
his unpopularity 73 of adults felt that
johnson was performing poorly
considering this overwhelming negative
feedback many members of johnson's inner
circle have already resigned like
allegra stratton johnson however has bit
his tongue and tried his best to at
least finish out his term so here's what
happened to boris johnson and why the uk
is demanding that he resign as prime
minister
taking a look back the route of
johnson's unpopularity can be traced
back to march 23rd 2020. on this fateful
day the uk government issued a strict
stay-at-home lockdown across the country
restaurants pubs and non-essential
retailers were all told to close and
citizens were restricted to traveling
only to and from essential work but
despite these strict orders for citizens
and businesses it seems like johnson and
the staffers felt that these rules did
not apply to them in fact many pictures
and videos that would eventually be
leaked suggest that his inner circle had
very little regard for these
restrictions the first example of this
was a get-together that took place on
may 15 2020 at the time the official
restriction stated that people had to
maintain two meters worth of social
distancing and only a maximum of two
people from different households were
allowed to meet in a public place
judging from the picture though about a
dozen people were meeting in the garden
no one was wearing masks and social
distancing was basically non-existent
johnson has insisted that this was
simply a business meeting but the
inclusion of his wife and wine in the
meeting suggests otherwise moving
forward five days on may 20th 2020
johnson senior aide martin reynolds
invited roughly 30 to 40 staff members
to a garden picnic two of these invitees
were of course johnson and his wife
kerry who both attended reports suggest
that many of johnson's deaf members even
advised them that this get-together was
in violation of lockdown restrictions
yet johnson attended anyway and he has
denied receiving warnings about the
party's violations moving forward
another month we have johnson's 56th
birthday which took place on june 19th
2020. by this point covert restrictions
had been lightened up a decent amount
and gatherings up to six people were
allowed outdoors but for johnson's
birthday not only did 30 people gather
which is five times the permitted amount
but they would gather indoors
fortunately uk's covered restrictions
would lighten up even more starting on
july 17 2020 so it seemed like these
parties were something that johnson
could leave behind in the rearview
mirror in reality though the pandemic
had just begun
as we now know cobed cases would pick up
once again in late 2020 as the world
faced a second wave as a result on
october 31st 2020 johnson would announce
a second round of strict lockdowns just
like the first round restaurants pubs
gyms and non-essential retailers all had
to shut down for at least 4 weeks
johnson went on to apologize that
christmas may be very different that
year and that he hopes that taking early
action can prevent even more action from
being required despite this somber
speech just two weeks later on november
13th 2020 staff members would reportedly
attend a gathering with carrie johnson
at the prime minister's residence
similarly just two weeks after this on
november 27 2020 a party would be thrown
for johnson senior aide cleo watson and
johnson would even give a speech at this
event a few weeks later on december 14th
2020 johnson's conservative party would
host a full-on party after hq in
westminster
by now i think you get the gist of
what's going on while the nation was
under strict lockdown johnson and his
colleagues basically just continued on
with the daily life on december 17 2020
a leaving party was thrown at the
cabinet office similarly on january 14
2021 another gathering was hosted to
celebrate the departure of two private
secretaries by this point it was clear
that johnson did not accidentally make a
violation here and there his colleagues
and he were consistently violating cobra
restrictions week after week but the
nail in the coffin didn't come until
april 16 to 2021 this time the downing
street staff hosted not one but two
parties fortunately johnson did not
attend either of these and covert
restrictions were much looser by this
point as vaccines were pretty readily
available but what made these parties
faithful was their ill timing you see
just one week before these parties queen
elizabeth ii husband and prince philip
duke of edenberg passed away on april 9
2021 the funeral was planned for april
17th 2020 which meant the downing street
parties took place the night before the
funeral for obvious reasons much of the
uk felt that these parties were
extremely distasteful and disrespectful
this led to the press looking into the
prime minister's history with parties
and their findings would annihilate
johnson's reputation
over the next several months the media
along with investigators would uncover
more and more of the parties and
gatherings we just discussed and the
public would grow more and more
irritated with each discovery but the
piece of evidence that sent the public
over the edge was a leaked video of
johnson's press secretary allegra
stratton and a bunch of her colleagues
joking about a christmas business
meeting and not following social
distancing
would the prime minister condone uh how
are you chris
what's the answer i don't know i didn't
wasn't the party
[Laughter]
it's fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
shortly after the video was leaked
alarga would announce her resignation in
tears many people in the comments have
gone on to claim that the tears are fake
and that this is terrible acting but
personally i think the tears are in fact
genuine however like other comments have
pointed out the tears are likely not
because she's sorry for a mistake but
because she got caught and is about to
lose her job
after this video was leaked johnson had
no choice but to conduct an official
investigation into the matter johnson
would initially task cabinet secretary
simon case with conducting the
investigation but he would soon be
replaced by civil servant sue gray as it
was uncovered that one of the parties
took place at simon's own office over
the next month and a half sue would
conduct an investigation which uncovered
loads of quote extremely damning
evidence sue apparently found dozens of
photos showing johnson attending events
with extremely loose or no code
restrictions but unfortunately much of
this evidence has yet to be released and
it's unclear if it'll ever be released
you see sue was supposed to publish her
full 25 page report in the last week of
january but on january 28th it was
revealed that sue's report would only be
11 pages long and that key details would
be left out in order to quote unquote
avoid any prejudice to their
investigation on top of this johnson got
to review the contents of the reports
for three days before it was finally
published on january 31st 2022
unfortunately for john's senate some of
the worst public and political backlash
we've seen in modern history would
follow soon after
on the surface it seems like people are
pissed off that johnson didn't take kobe
that seriously when it comes to his
personal actions but i think people's
distaste for johnson is much more deep
rooted than him simply not taking covert
seriously a bunch of world leaders did
not take the pandemic that seriously but
they're not receiving the same backlash
that johnson is and i think the key
reason for this is that they were
consistent unlike johnson take trump for
example he didn't take the pandemic too
seriously he often held a massive
gatherings at the white house and he
even held a rally with thousands of
people in june of 2020 while trump did
receive a lot of criticism from the
media and the democrats republicans
didn't exactly turn on him because he
was consistent with his messaging
trump's entire premise was that the
illness was here to stay and that
everyone should return to normal life
including returning to work and school
whether you agree with this perspective
or not is besides the point the point is
that trump practiced what he preached
johnson however did not to please the
media and the part of the public johnson
implemented severe covered restrictions
but in his personal life he didn't
follow any of these this left quite a
sour taste in many british people's
mouths as it felt like johnson and his
colleagues thought that they were above
the law while everyday citizens were
limited from going to work attending
school and opening up the local
businesses johnson was behaving like
nothing was happening what's even more
surprising though than the public being
upset is that politicians are also upset
all the comments on the initial video i
showed you guys are gushing over how
crazy it is to finally see a politician
being held accountable and while i
agreed that it's nice that johnson's
peers are calling him out on his actions
i also think that many of them unlikely
have ulterior motives here's the thing
prime ministers aren't directly voted
for in the uk
rather british citizens vote for members
of parliament and the leader of the
majority party becomes a prime minister
as a result it's the local elections
that determine the national leader this
might be a bit confusing because it's
basically the opposite in the u.s
americans mainly just vote for a
president and all of their local
election choices are just the candidates
from the same party as a result it's an
american politician's best interest to
align with the winning candidate in the
uk though given that citizens don't vote
for the prime minister directly local
candidates don't really care about
aligning with the prime minister
in fact it would probably be beneficial
for them if boris johnson is ousted
because it gives them a chance to move
up with that being said johnson's
colleagues turning on him may have more
to do with politics than serving justice
but hey at least he's being held
accountable
at the end of the day johnson seemingly
elitist viewer along with his colleagues
lack of dependence on him have really
torn apart johnson's reputation
but johnson has had one saving grace
which is russia's invasion of ukraine
russia's invasion has turned
international attention away from
johnson and on to putin zelinski russia
ukraine nato and so on and so forth in
other words the severity of putin's
actions has made most people forget
about johnson's actions aside from
diverting attention russia's invasion
has given johnson the perfect
opportunity to redeem himself by
supporting ukraine letting in refugees
and acting as a western hero in the war
refugees countries had a
historic and proud role in
in taking refugees all of his efforts
seemed to be paying off as the distaste
for johnson has noticeably declined over
the past two months from 73 down to 63
johnson still has a lot of work to do to
win back support from his colleagues and
the public but given that uk's next
general election isn't taking place till
may 2nd 2024 johnson has plenty of time
to do damage control
also in terms of resignation given that
johnson hasn't already resigned it's
extremely unlikely that johnson will
resign due to partygate and johnson will
likely just finish out his term but
that's just what i think
do you guys think johnson should be
fired comment that down below
also drop a like if you think all
politicians need to be held more
accountable and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm ari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]